CHIPOTLE’S SHADY HISTORY:
Since 2008, Chipotle has had 10 scandals regarding
food poisoning which has affected thousands
of people spreading diseases like Hepatitis
A, Norovirus, E. Coli, Salmonella, and Clostridium
Perfringens.
And those are just the outbreaks that made
it to the news.
Many of you probably know people who were
food poisonined after eating at Chipotle,
or maybe it’s even happened to you.
Yet, despite all these red flags, Chipotle
is doing better than ever.
In the last 12 month period, Chipotle brought
in $8.4 billion in revenue and ended up profiting
$800 million.
Similarly, they’ve expanded to over 3000
locations across the US.
It’s not just their fundamentals that have
been doing well either.
Chipotle stock has also held up extraordinarily
well throughout the recession being down only
a mere 20%.
This pegs Chipotles valuation at $41 billion
which nearly makes them a top 10 food brand
in terms of market cap.
For perspective, that’s over 3 times larger
than Domino’s Pizza.
Given their popularity, you would think that
they addressing their food poisoning concerns
would be their top priority, and according
to their PR, it is.
But, when we look at the facts, they don’t
look nearly as favorable for Chipotle.
In fact, It actually looks like they’re
regressing given that their outbreaks tend
to affect more people today.
For example, their first outbreak in 2008
affected 22 customers.
Conversely, an outbreak in 2018 ended up affecting
700 people.
At first glance, you might think that this
is somewhat expected for a chain as large
as Chipotle.
When you’re serving that much food, you’re
bound to serve some that gets people sick.
But, this is not actually true.
McDonald’s, for example, has over 10 times
the number of locations all over the world.
Yet, their Wikipedia page only mentions the
word “outbreak” once and even that was
in the context of describing the Coronavirus
outbreak.
Conversely, Chipotle’s wikipedia page mentions
the work outbreak a whopping 91 times.
What makes this even more confusing is that
Chipotle uses much of the same food supply
chain as McDonalds.
So, what in the world is going on at Chipotle
and why do so many people choose to eat there
anyway.
BEFORE CHIPOTLE’S ISSUES:
To understand what’s going wrong at Chipotle,
we first have to take a look at their origin
because there was a point in time when Chipotle
wasn’t synonymous with food poisoning, granted
it’s been quite some time.
The story of Chipotle dates back to 1993 to
a man named Steve Ells.
Steve was a classically trained chef who had
a few years of experience working in the traditional
restaurant industry as a sous chef.
While this gig gave Steve some experience,
he knew from day one that he wanted to open
a fine dining restaurant.
Jumping to that from just being a sous chef
was quite a leap though.
So, at age 28, Steve borrowed $85,000 from
his friends and family and opened a small
burrito shop instead in Denver Colorado.
Initially, he estimated that he needed to
sell atleast 107 burritos per day to be profitable,
but ended up crushing this number.
By the end of the first month itself, Steve
was selling over a 1000 burritos per day.
This strong reception gave Steve the confidence
to take out an SBA loan and open additional
restaurants in Colorado.
We can’t give Steve all the credit though
as he had substantial help from his father.
You see, Steve’s father was a wealthy pharmaceutical
executive.
And while he was hesitant to invest at ground
zero, once he saw these results, he became
a massive investor putting in $1.5 million.
Despite having access to all this capital,
Steve was in no rush to open up a bunch of
restaurants or expand outside of the state
for two reasons.
For one, Steve strongly believed in keeping
the business simple and straightforward.
And this is very much a core principle of
Chipotle to this day.
I mean, this is basically their entire menu.
And two, turning Chipotle into a nationwide
giant was never Steve’s vision.
His goal was to simply get some experience
running Chipotle before switching over to
fine dining.
But, by 1998, it was becoming extremely difficult
to stick to this original vision simply due
to how well Chipotle was doing.
Instead of resisting, Steve would simply embrace
the change and go all in on Chipotle, opening
their first restaurant outside of Colorado
in 1998.
Now that Chipotle was no longer just a local
sensation, bigger investors would become interested,
particularly McDonalds.
McDonalds started off with a small stake,
but they would end up making Chipotle into
who they are today.
Over the next 7 years, McDonalds helped Chipotle
grow from 16 to locations to over 500 locations
by investing a whopping $360 million which
gave them a 90% stake in the company.
But, money wasn’t even the biggest asset
that McDonalds brought to the table.
Their primary contribution was of course their
experience.
While McDonalds gets a bad rep for selling
highly processed junk food, one thing you
can’t argue with is that they're exceptional
at selling said food.
They’ve honed in everything from marketing
and franchising to the supply chain and food
safety.
And this expertise was very much evident in
Chiptole’s flawless growth from 16 stores
to 500 stores.
But, unfortunately for Chipotle, McDonald’s
wouldn’t stick around forever.
AWAY WITH MCDONALDS:
While McDonald’s was crushing it with Chipotle,
the same could not be said about their own
business.
During the dotcom crash, McDonald’s stock
would sell of 75% and it would take them 8
years to return to their former highs.
While much of this was simply due to the state
of the economy, McDonald’s executives decided
that they had to stop spending so much effort
on relatively small investments like Chipotle
and instead focus on their own growth.
So, in 2006, they decided to take Chipotle
public and sell off their entire stake.
Despite all this selling pressure, Chipotle
went on to have an extremely successfully
IPO.
Before going public, Chipotle actually raised
their IPO price twice, but even with that,
Chipotle ended up rocketing 100% during their
first day as a public company.
This made Chipotle the second best restaurant
IPO since the dotcom crash.
This strong support from investors made it
seemed like Chipotle would have a smooth time
without McDonald’s.
But, almost immediately, you could see the
result.
Just two years later, Chipotle would have
their first notable health crisis in March
of 2008.
A Chipotle location in La Mesa, California
would be linked to 22 cases of Hepatitis A.
Just one month later, Chipotle would have
yet another outbreak.
This time the disease was Norovirus and it
ended up infecting 440 people.
So, what in the world happened within these
24 months?
Well, one of the most notable points was Chipotle’s
trend towards decentralization.
I don’t think you’d be surprised to hear
that McDonald’s was a strong proponent of
centralized operations.
Virtually all of their ingredients come from
mass distributors like Keystone Foods.
Every year, Keystone Foods alone delivers
150 million pounds of beef, 300 million pounds
of chicken, and 15 million pounds of fish
to McDonalds.
While this style of supply chain raises a
lot of questions regarding animal treatment,
perservatives, and GMOs, one thing that’s
not in question is consistency.
When all of your food comes from one location,
it’s all gonna be the same.
More importantly though, a simplified supply
chain makes it easy to maintain quality and
identify issues quickly.
Given that much of Chipotle’s entire brand
is built around simplicity, you would think
that Steve would stick to a centralized supply
chain, but he actually had other plans.
You see, Steve had caught sense of a new food
trend which pushed people to ditch junk food
and eat healthier.
Being an opportunistic business man, Steve
decided to jump onto this trend of producing
quote on quote organic locally sourced food.
Looking back, this was a perfect choice in
terms of their marketing and branding, and
it’s also the ethical choice.
But, this turned out to be a nightmare in
terms of quality control.
SUPPLY CHAIN HELL:
Today, Chipotle tries to source as many ingredients
as possible from within a 350 mile radius.
While this locally grown produce sounds great
on paper, there’s a reason that mega food
corporations shy away from this idea.
It’s because it’s virtually impossible
to maintain standards across thousands of
suppliers, and Chipotle would figure this
out the hard way.
This decentralized supply chain also put a
lot of strain on Chipotle’s stores because
their stores were built to operate in the
exact opposite manner: with simplicity.
Chipotle locations don’t have any freezers,
microwaves, or even can openers.
This means that the staff have to take on
a lot of the responsibility when it comes
to preparing the food.
Given that it’s a restaurant, you would
think that this would be a given, but it’s
not.
Most fast food places structure their business
such that fast food workers don’t have to
do much preparation.
Basically everything comes premade meaning
that the workers simply have to heat up the
food or assemble it.
Chipotle workers on the other hand are literally
given raw ingredients.
I mean, they literally make the food in front
of you.
This would be ok if we were talking about
an actual sit down restaurant filled with
experienced staff.
But, most Chipotle locations are run by young
adults and high school students, so there’s
a massive learning curve.
In 2015 and 2016, during the worst of Chipotle’s
outbreaks, Chipotle actually spent a lot of
effort on strengthening their training programs.
But, this quickly led them to yet another
issue: employee turnover.
Just as employees start to get the hang of
things, they leave.
In 2021, Chipotle’s turnover rate was 194%.
This means that the average employee barely
sticks around for 4 months which is not surprising
given that it’s a near minimum wage job.
Chipotle has tried to combat this by handing
out cash and stock bonuses, offering maternity/paternity
coverage, and even offering life insurance
and short term disability.
But, none of this can change the fundamental
fact that in the end, it’s still a fast
food job.
And this is really the story of Chipotle as
a whole.
They’re trying to do all these great things
like sourcing local food and promoting healthier
options, but they’re still a fast food place
and they have to deal with all of the limitations
that come along with that.
And these issues are only made worse by seemingly
negligent leadership.
While Steve started Chipotle with a great
passion for food, it seems that over the years,
he has become much more interested in the
money.
In fact, Chipotle is infamous for paying their
executives ridiculous sums of money.
Back in the early 2010s, Chipotle paid out
$300 million to their co CEOs.
These guys were earning FAANG CEO type salaries
even though Chipotle was pulling in less than
1% of the revenue of companies like Apple
or Google.
Not to mention, their profit margins were
way lower as well.
Shareholders did eventually put their foot
down and refused to approve such compensation
packages, but this just goes to show where
their executives priorities really were.
THE STATE OF CHIPOTLE:
Considering all this, why in the world do
people continue to eat at Chipotle?
Well, the answer is simple.
As this quora user puts it Chipotle actually
serves real food or atleast realer food than
other fast food joints.
Real food comes with real flavors that create
a unique appeal, but they also come with real
risk.
The only way to avoid this risk is to cook
yourself, spend a fortune on eating out, or
eat highly processed foods.
And given that most people are one, too lazy
to cook themselves, two, not rich enough to
eat out at 5 star restaurants regularly, and
three want something more than McDonalds or
Burger King junk, they flock to something
in the middle which just so happens to be
Chipotle.
So, Chipotle’s greatest strength is also
their biggest weakness.
And they only have two options moving forward.
They can recentralize like the legacy competition,
or they can try to fix what they already have.
It’s clear which side Chipotle has chosen,
and looking at their fundamentals, it’s
working out just fine.
Are you a fan of Chipotle?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re a fan of real
food.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.